[Music]
there is a motto which has been borne by
many of my ancestors
a noble motto
i serve
those words were an inspiration to many
bygone heirs to the throne
when they made their nightly dedication
as they came to manhood
i cannot quite do as they do
but through the inventions of science
i can do what was not possible for any
of them
i could make my solemn act of dedication
with a hell empire listening
i should like to make that dedication
now
it is very simple
i declare before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great imperial
family which we all belong
[Music]
[Music]
from the young elizabeth it was quite
some promise
a promise
she would keep
leaving her home on what will surely be
the greatest day of her life queen
elizabeth drives to her coronation
through decades of incessant change
she was to be a constant
preceded by her guards and escorted by
her cavalry she drives through cheering
crowds down the guiley decorated avenue
of the marrow
steadfast ever present reassuring a
queen whose devotion would earn the
respect of the world
madam
is your majesty willing to take the
earth
i am willing
a much-loved woman a remarkable reign
the monarch of our times
the climax of the ceremony has arrived
when the archbishop gently sets this
splendid emblem on the queen's head
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
elizabeth alexandra mary windsor was
born into the most extraordinary life
her early life was the life of a
relatively normal family a family that
wanted to be away from the prying eyes
of the cameras
[Music]
princess elizabeth's father was the shy
unassuming duke of york
during dutchess of york her parents
didn't have to do very much in this is
not nearly as much as members of the
royal family do these days
they were a close and loving family
princess elizabeth and her sister
margaret were to spend much of their
childhood in scotland
i think
scotland from that age onwards was
always the fun place where you could go
a bit wild you know
i mean we played a game called catching
happy days
which involved rolling around the garden
at great speed catching the leaves as
they fell off the trees
um that kept us happy all day you can't
imagine children with
ipads and every sort of funny game
being content to that sort of thing yeah
i think of the two young princesses
princess elizabeth was always a
serious-minded one
she had a wonderful sense of humor but
basically she was serious
but had a really nice sort of elder
sisterly
regard for her
little sister
they were
quite often with their parents more so
perhaps in other children of the same
class
but of course it was very different in
those days
in all these processions and in the
groups on the balconies the public
caught charming glimpses of the young
princess who was third in line of
succession to the throne
i think she realized that she had a a
public side as well as a private side
even at quite a young age really
that was the way you behaved it i don't
think she thought of herself as
tremendously different to other children
but on the other hand there were certain
restrictions that
she would have accepted as
necessary
both the parents
always
brought the two children up
with the idea of duty and and
selflessness really
the line of succession was never
supposed to pass through her father
he was the king's younger brother and
second in line to the throne
britain had found herself faced by a
constitutional dilemma unprecedented
even in her long and eventual history
within months of his coronation princess
elizabeth's uncle edward viii was faced
with a choice between marrying the woman
he loved or remaining as king
i have found it impossible to carry the
heavy burden of responsibility
and to discharge my duties as cain
as i would wish to do
without the help and support of the
woman
i love
king edward abdicated there's a
dereliction of duty on his part
he'd let everybody down let the family
down
and it was a decision that was to have
dramatic consequences for the young
elizabeth
the fact that it was ultimately going to
affect her too and the nature of how her
life would panic was probably too
difficult to comprehend for one so young
but it did change her life
and
his decision as king edward viii to
leave
would ensure that she would one day be
queen
when princess elizabeth watched her
father's coronation it was more than an
exciting spectacle at just 10 years old
she now knew it was also her destiny
[Music]
she knew she would one day be queen
it naturally completely changed their
life
this young elizabeth whose life was set
to be one of living a relatively
comfortable life suddenly
was to have the ultimate job of
responsibility but also a job of course
that she had no choice over
realizing her path was pre-ordained she
made a decision a life of public duty
involved great personal sacrifice one
she was more than prepared to make
she had seen the impact that her uncle's
abdication had had on her father
to turn your back on not only an
obligation but on something that in the
process of coronation you are
anointed to do
and i think this worked really deep into
her
psyche about what the job
that she had undertaken
was it wasn't a job it was a way of life
when the breeze blew the king's hair
over his forehead as he studied the map
princess elizabeth reacted to her own
ideas of how he should look before the
cameras
knowing she would succeed him the
princess observed her father closely
the apprenticeship intensified as the
second world war started she needed to
grow into her role of air quickly and
she did
the world's greatest city writes in
flames an epic of courage that stirs the
hearts of free men everywhere
[Music]
princess elizabeth was only 14 when she
gave her first radio broadcast to
children all over the empire
as we know from experience
what it means to be away from those we
love most of all
to you living in new surroundings we
send a message of true sympathy
my sister is by my side
and we are both going to say good night
to you
come on margaret
good night children
good night and good luck to you all
the princess was desperate to serve this
was an opportunity to prove herself
she convinced the king to let her join
the army driving and fixing ambulances
she was of her generation which was a
wartime generation and the sort of keep
calm carry on
philosophy
was absolutely embedded in her
she joined the auxiliary territorial
service became a remarkably good driver
and always
to the end of her life loved to drive
and loved to worry about engines and
knew about them
[Applause]
the day the war ended princess
elizabeth's parents let her slip into
the crowds outside buckingham palace
incognito with her sister and cousin
[Music]
i mean you can't imagine what london was
like when the war ended
[Music]
we walked a long way we went all the way
up to elder scroll and then all the way
down piccadilly
it was just a euphoric moment
and then then they
we ended up in front of buckingham
palace again
and joining this huge crowd and shouting
we want the king
victory for europe and a rare moment of
freedom for princess elizabeth
she later called it one of the most
memorable nights of her life
but the war was an exception normal life
for an heir is constrained and lonely
the princess needed someone in her life
to make the future less daunting
prince philip was a very dashing young
navy cadet when the queen first laid
eyes on him in fact she met him when she
was 13
and he was at dartmouth naval college
and by all accounts it was love at first
sight for her and she was smitten by him
now the king and queen had plans that
the ideal consort to princess elizabeth
who was going to be queen one day would
be one of the descendants of the ducal
families of england
but she wasn't interested in that
it's almost the only time when the queen
absolutely stepped out of line queen
elizabeth her mother would have loved
her to marry a grenadier guard
it was perfectly evident to anyone who
saw the queen when prince philip walked
into the room she would just completely
light up it was the days luckily before
ghastly emails and things that
that
somehow or other
aren't the same as letters
i mean he was a god-like good-looking i
mean it's not remotely surprising that
you fell in love with him
when i married
princess
elizabeth and princess margaret were all
bridesmaids
and prince philip was an usher
and there's a photograph of prince
philip as an usher
taking the queen's fur rap from her
for some reason that absolutely caught
people's imagination it was published
and i think from then on um
people began to think oh
you know and i i suppose red is probably
the point in which i thought oh
and how nice i would have thought
this love would endure almost her whole
life but before she married him she had
an even more important vow to make that
21st birthday dedication to service
i declare before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
god help me to make good my vow
and god bless all of you
who are willing to share in it
the first person willing to share in her
vow of duty was prince philip
he was his own man and elizabeth her own
woman but together
they were a team
he and i had breakfast alone on the
morning of his wedding we talked a
little bit about it and he did say to me
i don't know whether i'm being very
brave or very foolish
and i said you are being very brave
and i'm sure it will be a great success
and how right i was
elizabeth and her husband waved to the
cheering crowds
he became for the queen
her great strength and stay
she loved him she was infatuated with
him i mean she was he was beautiful she
you know this beautifully attractive
dashing athletic
young man who fell in love with her
the royal highness is the proud and
happy mother of a prince and in the
monarch's home lies the infant boy who
will one day be king they had their
first two children prince charles and
princess anne the princess and elizabeth
alice louise newly christened and lovely
in the traditional christening frog
and when prince philip was given a naval
posting in malta it was the young
couple's chance to live a more carefree
and private life
i think that was the
by far the happiest time
of their lives because they were least
constricted and the media didn't wasn't
always trying to get at them all the
time
but life would not be normal for long
the public did not know it yet but the
king had lung cancer and his health was
deteriorating
he sent princess elizabeth on a tour of
africa in his place
when she was aged just 25.
she waved goodbye to her father excited
to represent him abroad not imagining
the tragedy just days away that would
turn her world
upside down
the heart of the nation stops
the flags lower in tribute
over the mother of parliaments high over
big ben the flag is low as the news
spreads
the king is dead
[Music]
the queen's father died aged 56 his
reign and her apprenticeship cut short
prince philip broke the news to the
queen at a lodge deep in the kenyan bush
i mean it must have been just the most
horrendous shock ever i don't think that
the first thought was how am i going to
cope with being queen i think the first
thought was
my darling father's died
the death of a parent can be a
catastrophe
for a
daughter who loves her father it is
probably even more so
but when you not only take on being
sovereign
but you have to walk down the steps
having been away when he died
and face winston churchill and his
serious looking
cabinet
who do you go to for advice there isn't
anyone
in that moment
and all accounts sort of say that she
kind of gulped gathered herself
and then knew that that was her destiny
a grieving daughter but also now the
queen
in a way that she could never have
imagined
[Music]
she descended the steps draped in grief
knowing her life would never be the same
again
[Music]
[Applause]
for crowning over the queen emerges to
find that the weather had been unkind
but in spite of the gloom of the wet her
majesty looked radiant as she moved to
the coach
queen elizabeth's coronation was the
first live television event in history
and tens of millions of people tuned in
[Applause]
she was very conscious of the fact that
she needed to be out there to be visible
going right back to televising the
coronation i think she had an instinct
for knowing that that was important for
the role that she she had
[Applause]
a modern queen for a new television age
ushering in a post-war era of optimism
and hope
the new queen was beautiful she
presented this icon of hope after all
the austerity of the second world war
and her reign beginning in the shock of
the king's death came with the
opportunity of this young new start
they saw in her coronation this young
woman of 26 dedicating herself to serve
and
that kicked off the reign of elizabeth
ii with all the very best bells ringing
the new queen was glamorous and elegant
and this was a golden couple in high
demand
dancing smiling meeting and greeting
their way around state visits
commonwealth tours and garden parties
but time was made every week for the
queen to meet the prime minister
the queen was a young woman um and she
was entering a very male world her first
prime minister was winston churchill he
was a huge presence in every sense she
was a a small young woman
i asked the prime ministers progressed i
think some of them
when they were very new didn't quite
realize how extraordinarily
well-informed she was
and
had perhaps not done their homework well
enough and went away and made sure that
they did their homework for the next
time it was that first meeting with her
as prime minister for someone who'd been
a little boy
in the streets of durham waving your
flag when she drove through in the 1960s
and suddenly they were your prime
minister
but then she also said to me you know
you were my 10th prime minister the
first was winston churchill and that was
before you were born
so it kind of put you in your historical
place as it were
for each prime minister i think the
reassurance of spending time with her
not so much because she will give the
answer to their problems but because
they can unburden them they can say
anything to her with absolute confidence
and she's taken all those secrets to the
grave
at sir winston churchill's funeral the
queen did not arrive last or leave first
as was her royal privilege she stayed
throughout
a sign of deep respect for her first
prime minister
she had a genuine empathy i think for
the people that were in this position of
power because she she understood the the
pressures you know even today
i wouldn't
know what the politics of the queen
really were maybe a better way of
putting it is that she
she was really above
politics
becoming queen just after world war ii
there was no role more solemn and
profound than that of commander-in-chief
the queen learnt to be a good
commander-in-chief by watching her
father in the war
most of her reign
was marked by
the armed forces being in some way
deployed somewhere in the world for the
interests of the united kingdom on the
decisions of prime ministers
and yet each of those soldiers sailors
and men and women were dedicated by the
oath to serve her
[Music]
here is somebody who served in the
military who is a veteran who has a
family that has served in the military
so she understands
her majesty is the warrior queen she has
done it she's been there she's seen it
and she makes good judgment and because
of that
everyone within the armed services shows
complete and utter loyalty to her
majesty
it was a very special relationship that
between our monarch and the head of the
armed forces knowing that we owed our
loyalty to the queen was very special
she knew so many people who had died in
war and she she realized so much better
than most of us the costs of war
the elizabethan era coincided with the
end of empire and the queen became the
face of the modern commonwealth
[Music]
the queen's reign has seen a very marked
change in attitudes to empire she's
probably
going to be looked at by history as the
last
imperial monarch i think the queen
herself as a person embodied
so well the aspirations of the
commonwealth to represent democracies
freedoms and all those other elements
that make commonwealth nations shares
common values
it meant that some countries that were
never part of the old british empire
chose to be a part of the comrade
her majesty is having here the closest
contact with her subject since she came
to the throne i think that the queen
made sure
in her reign that there was room
always
for reinvention
for reinspection of the past and for
finding a route
effortlessly by just being there as head
she's enabled
that group of nations to find a route
forward and
i think that's something she can always
be very proud of
when foreigners think of the uk they
think of the queen
so this i think
gave her unique
uh interest
around the world because she wasn't just
a person
she was the embodiment of a country
the queen became the uk's diplomat in
chief trying to bring together a world
riven by war
the queen for me was our top diplomat
our best diplomat she was the best known
and she was the best at the work
and i don't think anybody will ever
match that
the queen
was representative of a generation that
saw both
japan and germany try and destroy
britain and i think that must have
formed her it certainly formed her
husband who fought in the war in the
royal navy
and i think both of them sought always
to try and encourage a peaceful world
because of the cataclysm of violence and
misery that they'd witnessed
and throughout their lives they did
their best on behalf of and when
recommended to by governments of the day
to reach out friendship
not long after the war the queen invited
the leader of germany and later japan to
the uk she would visit both countries in
return one of her most important
missions was
reconciliation we cannot forget the past
but we must build on the future
you and i have spent most of our lives
believing that this evening could never
happen
she
never thought that she would see russia
or china in the course of her reign she
saw both
the queen's schedule was planned out
years in advance each visit and foreign
trip crafted down to the last detail but
things didn't always go to plan
you for your warm welcome to washington
and to the white house
awkwardly her speech outside the white
house could be heard but not seen
the talking hat moment hit the headlines
but she had the last laugh a few days
later at congress i'll give you your
speeches
and you wait there for the welcome which
comes from above from the speaker
sitting above you
and
it is going to be built
for you and for anyone else this time
not something that i would ever have
actually thought about beforehand
i'm told there will be many
interruptions
nice buttons friendly ones yes
absolutely
i think the tourism
um
quite enjoyed moments when things went
wrong
mr speaker her majesty queen elizabeth
ii his royal highnesses
[Applause]
i do hope you can see me today from
where you are
i think whichever member of the royal
family you are you were surrounded with
people
or your private secretaries ladies and
gentlemen policemen whose job is to make
their life
go smoothly
so obviously when something goes wrong
you know you think it's disaster but
they think it's wonderful because
they've got something different to talk
about at dinner
away from the pressures of diplomacy and
duty her scottish home was her refuge
and family sanctuary a more private
space for children and grandchildren to
let loose
i suppose belmodel is a place one looks
forward to very much as the
summer goes on
i think that it has an atmosphere if
it's of its own
you just hibernate
but it's rather nice to hibernate for a
bit when one leads such a very
movable life to be able to sleep in the
same bed for
six weeks is a nice change
holidays were always really important to
the queen she
looked forward to being with her family
which was a
a real treasure for her all of them you
know to get them together and it was one
of the only occasions because they were
all representing her in different parts
of the world or country and in a way
it's a family that was so divided by
what united them
that getting them all together during
the holidays was perfect
the more than 60 years she did those
state occasions the walkabouts the
meeting you know hundreds of thousands
of people
what an ordeal for someone who would
much rather
be out in the countryside or actually
just at home being quiet and probably
being quite shy um it's kind of
remarkable when you think of it like
that
you've got your red boots they're very
nice aren't they
that's very smart yeah
if she hadn't happened to be
born
to be queen
she'd have been a happy country woman
with with masses of horses and dogs and
who would have been as happy as anything
right bathroom's in there oh it's my
foot you're standing on okay
now should we go that way yeah we want
to go in the sun that way i think that
she'll always be remembered for the fact
that she
regarded horses and dogs as probably
more interesting than people you always
knew the queen was around because a
couple of corgis would come through the
door first
and they were the sort of vanguard and
in a way
they broke the ice
princess elizabeth visiting hurst park
arrived before the first race
there isn't much that she did as queen
that benefited herself personally
but i think she probably did invest a
touch too much in the horses she loved
her racing though it was her distraction
and she
never was as successful as she might
have liked to have been on the racetrack
she's spent her whole life
for basically 70 years now owning
racehorses and breeding resources she
she gets her relief
from bringing up her trainers and stud
managers in the evening times and
hearing about her horses and that's her
release
from all the other stuff that goes on in
her life which is a lot
do you know that i haven't watched a
pair of binoculars for ages look at it
boring tears oh dear
and i always watch on the television
it's the emotion no no i watch the
television if you look
the queen was absolutely hilarious she
used to mimic people she had the most
marvelous stories tremendous diffidence
about herself and she would often make
people laugh
in private at the most extraordinary
situations that she'd found herself in
[Music]
the middle of conversation would be a
dead accurate rendition of somebody in
public life it always sort of
caught me by surprise
[Music]
it was quite
an impish sense of humor she took a
certain i think delight and slightly
catching one out um but never malevolent
always good human and always
constructive and wanting to make one
improve i'm not doing that again you
know
so marvellous
her sense of humor was not something
most people got to see close up the
queen drew a firm line between public
and private
she recognized that with the media less
is more she didn't give interviews
and never
um
was tempted to
i don't think the queen has
significantly let people into her life
let the press into her life part of the
role of monarch of course is to seem
present but actually seem quite distant
because being too accessible
in a way lets too much light in it it
shatters the image of monarchy it breaks
the spell the magic of monarchy
[Music]
the queen's true feelings were mostly
hidden behind her public persona but
there were moments when she would
briefly let the world in
[Music]
1992
is not a year
on which i shall look back with
undiluted
pleasure the words of one of my more
sympathetic correspondence
it has turned out to be an anus or
rebellious
the marriages of her three oldest
children ended that year
the most bitter and wrenching being the
split of prince charles and diana
princess of wales once celebrated as the
glamorous future king and queen
it's bad enough to go through that
trauma
as a private individual but they have to
do it in the full glare of publicity
must be
incredibly difficult
diana had very quickly become the most
popular royal her beauty and style
empathy and vulnerability marked her out
from other members of the family she was
the people's princess
she was a princess and a member of the
royal family but she was also a global
figure
someone who who had brought a lot of
change
to the monarchy in the way that it
operated
her shocking death triggered a crisis
for the queen
generally speaking what's been
remarkable about the queen is she's
remained in step with her people over
you know so many decades but there has
been moments where it seemed that she
has been out of step and i think the
most significant one was after the death
of diana and it was really
an incredible 10 days where it seemed
really like there was almost like
the united kingdom on the cusp of some
kind of civil war
i'm learning from the press association
now that dinah princess of wales has
died
[Music]
princess diana's death was a global
event huge global significance i mean
it's hard to understand that
from the perspective of today and
therefore the queen
all the way through
the the succeeding days after the death
was both trying to perform her her role
as monarch but also grieving
and
anxious about
the children and and and how to protect
them
diana's children princes william and
harry were on holiday at balmoral at the
time of the crash the queen
stayed with them
the boys were the center of her thinking
the thought that she should come down
and sit in buckingham palace with two
little bereaved boys with absolutely
nothing to do
except grieve
would be the last thing you'd want to
suggest she it was much more sensible to
keep the boys in scotland doing things i
think she understood that
if she could channel or take or or
shoulder the anger of the nation at what
had happened
that in its own way would have been a
service not just
to the nation but
to this thing that she
was probably more dedicated to than
anyone will realize which was
her family her love for her son for her
grandsons
for the mother of her grandsons the
british public behaved in the most
extraordinary way over diana
and they were hysterical
i think she probably felt well surely my
duty is to stay with my grandchildren
not with this hysteric people
dropping flowers all the time
the queen will always be criticized
for having put her family in a very
special place in her concerns and i
think that that's a criticism
that she will gladly wear
whatever her intentions these were
testing times for the queen
people began to demand she returned to
london to fly the palace flag at
half-mast to honor diana's memory
they wanted to see the queen they wanted
actions and the headlines in london you
know where are you mom there was a real
sense of a sort of baying crowds with
the queen just not responsive to her
people
it was very difficult to to work out
how
to do the right thing in these
circumstances and all the way through i
was
concerned to try and protect the
monarchy because there was at the time
a backlash if you like and i think it
must be quite an unpleasant time
uh to have to go out and meet the crowd
and and wondering really where they
was it going to be a hostile reception
was this a moment that was going to
literally end the inheritance as people
were sometimes saying
[Music]
when they finally did come down to
london
it was almost the country holding its
breath and i remember watching thinking
are they gonna start booing the queen
and they got out of the car and there
was this harsh silence
there was just this slow ripple of
applause and it was like
the country kind of exhaled
it was my job to meet her outside the
gates
and escorted her and prince philip
outside where she met the crowd
and looked all the flowers
and you can see the queen was visibly
touched about all that
the queen all the way through was
listening to the advice she was trying
to work out the right thing to do in the
end she came to her own view ultimately
that she had to come
and to speak
this week at belmoral we have all been
trying to help william and harry come to
terms with the devastating loss
that they and the rest of us have
suffered
no one who knew diana will ever forget
her
millions of others who never met her
but felt they knew her will remember her
i for one believe there are lessons to
be drawn from her life
and from the extraordinary and moving
reaction to her death
but for a time it really did look like
she perhaps dropped a ball and the
the monarchy was you know really rocking
and i think that was probably
its most vulnerable point during the
queen's reign
it could have been extremely difficult
for the royal family i think it was a
moment of real vulnerability but on the
other hand
she was acutely aware of that the queen
and she was
she showed ultimately that she was
completely capable of dealing with it
green's life has been a continual
process of evaluation reevaluation you
know after princess diana's death that
was a big moment of recalibration and
and the royal family did it and she led
it
i think there was a sense of reassessing
the institution throughout that period
and a lot of it came to fruition after
the death of the princess
[Music]
the kind of events that the queen was
doing
the communication side was revamped the
reduction of the civil list of royal
finances the queen and the royal family
paying tax the opening of buckingham
palace
all institutions in britain that want to
survive must consistently reinvent
themselves and the queen from the day
she became sovereign to the day she died
understood the need for that reinvention
and if you compare the court that was
surrounding her on the day she died with
the one that she walked into of that
aircraft from kenya it is quite
remarkable how much change the queen saw
to it
that took place through her reign
but if the death of diana brought change
to the monarchy there was no end to the
personal heartache for the queen her
sister died and soon afterwards her
mother
elizabeth was now the matriarch in a
monarchy with an uncertain future
[Music]
change has become a constant
managing it has become an expanding
discipline
the way we embrace it defines our future
for if a jubilee becomes a moment to
define an age
then for me we must speak of change
its breadth and accelerating pace over
these years
i would like above all to declare my
resolve to continue
with the support of my family
to serve the people of this great nation
of ours
to the best of my ability
through the changing times ahead
the queen took it upon herself to
restore her relationship with the people
her golden jubilee was the litmus test
we had to construct a year that really
one had a sense that we'd moved on that
there was a turning of a page
what we didn't know
was
what the
public reaction was going to be
it was a turning point the queen had won
back people becoming convinced this was
a monarchy that had lost touch the moves
to modernize an institution falling from
favor had worked
if you imagine
looking out on a crowd of what the
police estimated was a million people
and looking down the mile you couldn't
see an inch of ground or grass i mean
there were people everywhere
it felt like a celebration and that's
what it was
the queen had seen the monarchy through
its time of challenge it was also the
beginning of a new century and a whole
new generation of people were getting to
know queen elizabeth ii
to people of all ages she was now the
most recognizable person in the world
and a global icon
in this mass media age almost nobody is
known to everybody
so the queen was in a unique position
for
decade after decade and disappearing
from everybody's life i think will touch
the lives of everybody
the queen was enormously popular
globally
i mean she was an iconic figure it
didn't matter how republican the country
was i mean they were absolutely thrilled
to be with her they were always as it
were in the presence of a star bigger
than them i mean she she does happen the
royal family has i mean enormous soft
power influence
and nowhere was that soft power more in
evidence than in ireland in 2011
she was the first reigning monarch to
visit in more than a century
on display was an awareness of history
and a deaf touch that made friends of
old enemies
at the state banquet she delighted the
guests by greeting the irish president
sat next to her in gaelic
uh
argus akoja
to all those who have suffered as a
consequence of our troubled past
i extend my sincere thoughts and deep
sympathy
with the benefit of historical hindsight
we can all see things which we would
wish had been done differently
or not at all the queen i think stepped
into areas that were just compulsively
brave
emblematic and powerful leaving the
doors open for the politicians to try
and weave closer ties
afterwards and i think that was her role
to enable behind her the political
process of bonding to take place
[Music]
the queen's mantra you had to be seen to
be believed held true even after she
turned 90.
[Music]
her majesty
is one of the hardest working people
i've ever met in my life
for somebody of her age the things she
was doing the event she was attending
sometimes three events in a day it was
absolutely remarkable
any of these events you'd have upwards
of 200 people
uh there that hamachi would meet in the
process of doing that
he's excellency the president of malta
and miss villius man
good morning good morning
well it was fun being a private
secretary and one of my predecessors
said you never
come out of your morning session with
the queen feeling worse than when you
went in she had a sense of humor she was
very interested in people
it was my privilege to see her majesty
quite a lot
and in all those interactions there was
a courtesy and a humanity and a kindness
that i'll remember forever
throughout her life the queen made
personal sacrifices the good of the firm
came before the good of individual
members of the family the queen
would say when confronted with an issue
what should the queen do in other words
not what should i do but what should i
do in my position as queen
when prince andrew was accused of
sexually assaulting a 17 year old girl
swift action was taken
he denied the allegations but despite
being rumored to be the queen's favorite
son andrew was stripped of his military
titles forced to withdraw from public
life
yes this is a royal family and yes she
was a wife a daughter a mother
but ultimately the royal family is a
firm
and the queen has been the boss of that
firm and she's been a pretty hardcore
chief executive really and she's put
that and we've seen that across her
reign a critical moment she's put the
good of the firm
perhaps over and above her own
particular personal emotions and
feelings at particular points in time
there was sadness too at the departure
of the duke and duchess of sussex who
left the firm amid accusations of racism
and a painful family split
prince harry moved his family to america
as a grandmother must have been
incredibly painful and difficult but
basically she said you know either
you're part of the the firm the family
and you're a work involved or you're not
and i think in the statements that were
made around that time they were actually
quite emotional they they did actually
encapture
i think that dual sense of her as queen
but also the pain that she felt as a
grandmother and as a mother
through all the sort of travels that
like any family because the royal family
in the end is a family through all the
travels that they've had she has
always
had to overcome those and just remain
solid and clear in her duty as the queen
anyone who was in her family
was a treasure to her
and she recognized and probably felt a
burden of responsibility
that whatever problems they faced they
were magnified because she was queen
and there aren't many mothers or
grandmothers or great-grandparents who
have to deal with that additional burden
[Music]
at the same time the british public was
facing its toughest peacetime challenge
in a century the global coronavirus
pandemic
the queen would once again choose her
moment to speak directly to the country
offering a message of strength and a
reference to the resolve of her wartime
generation
we should take comfort that while we may
have more still to endure
better days will return
we will be with our friends again
we will be with our families again
we will meet again if we look back at
what happened during uh the covert
epidemic when our majesty dressed the
nation it's the empathy we're all in
this together but it's going to be okay
and i think that comes from her
majesty's vast experience
[Music]
experience could prepare her for many
things but perhaps nothing as painful as
losing her husband
buckingham palace
has just announced that the duke of
edinburgh has died he was 99 years old
whenever we look back on the queen's
reign and her successes we have to pay
tribute to prince philip because
you know she would have been nothing
without him i think that's actually not
an over statement i think he
he gave her confidence you know she
described and lamented the loss of him
[Music]
his sense of service
intellectual curiosity
and capacity to squeeze fun out of any
situation were all irrepressible
[Music]
that mischievous inquiring twinkle
was as bright at the end as when i first
set eyes on him
at his funeral the queen sat alone
refusing to make an exception to the
rules even
for herself
but he has quite simply been my strength
and stay all these years
and i and his whole family
and this and many other countries owe
him a debt greater than he would ever
claim for we shall ever know
what she has maintained
is a
serenity
but you know that there is a deep
compassion
underneath that and those images of her
at the funeral of prince philip i think
say it all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think she's left the most marvelous
benchmark for people who seek
to lead
to do it selflessly
quietly
with a sense of decorum no rush to say
anything in a hurry or whatever the
modern world demands
[Applause]
my abiding memory of the queen will be
of someone who
became monarch in one era ending up
in a completely different era today
[Music]
most of us have never remembered a
different monarch who ever known a
different monarch had never known a
coronation
i did remark that it was upside down and
you wouldn't be able to see what was on
it i thought it had to be upside down
for the president
[Laughter]
people
knew the queen
she had been there for
all the life of nearly everybody alive
on the planet e welcome
to queen elizabeth critical care unit
it's amazing isn't it what can be done
when when need needs be in order to
um
be relevant you've got to change uh
because the world outside is changing
and she was the first to recognize this
in the old expression you had to change
every day to stay the same it's been
very nice to be able to join you and
also to hear hear what happened and how
well it has been achieved
thank you thank you very much indeed all
of you
[Music]
in later life the queen carefully chose
the right moments to let the public see
her more playful side she had a knack
for knowing what to agree to and when
thank you for having me
i do hope you're having a lovely jubilee
tea
oh yes please
she allowed herself to connect with
without
despoiling what she represented but i
think it was by doing it she enhanced
the nature of being sovereign for a
changing and evolving nation
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
i always keep one for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
for later it delighted the world because
they weren't expecting it and because
they thought
that she was not the kind of person who
would allow her front to drop in that
sense
happy jubilee man
and
thank you
for everything
that's very kind
[Applause]
your majesty
mommy
you pledged to serve your whole life
you continue to deliver
these pictures
on your house
are the story of your life
and ours
you have met us and talked with us
you laugh and cry with us
and most importantly
you have been there for us for these
seventy years
we will have great britain without the
queen but we will miss the queen
because the queen was there for so long
and through so many upheavals in our
national life and in international life
and through all those upheavals
she was steady and comforting
she never wavered from duty or service
i promise you if we live a thousand
years we'll never see anything like it
again you couldn't i mean it just it
just cannot be
i can't see how
the likes of the queen will reappear in
a hurry
all those years of wisdom and compassion
we've been so so lucky
she has really done it in her way that
really important sense of duty
i think has
been there throughout
it was a life of service and a life of
duty
she has given this sense of
calm stability which is always there has
always been there and i think that has
been her extraordinary contribution
there wasn't anything imagined he
couldn't do you know she genuinely cared
and she led all the way
every day
she had a long-term view
of what the monarchy was about which is
essentially duty
as the head of state to unify and bring
together the british people she adhered
to that she was the best exponent of it
the challenge she had was
unparalleled for the modern monarchy
and yet she rose to it magnificently
because she reigned for so long
we will find the tentacles of her
contribution to public life
we will unwrap the character that she
showed to so many people over the years
to come
and if there is a heaven she will have
found herself face to face with her
father and the greatest motivation for
her time as queen
that he should say
i'm proud of you
[Music]
you